so today we're going to try uh something
a little different again i always like
doing this because as you're a
theocratic fascist dictator one of my
duties is to listen to the people and
hear their problems and uh and then
judge them ruthlessly thankfully
reddit's am i the apple forum provides
us plenty of fuel for this
whole fire
take a listen
am i the tool for kicking my husband out
of the delivery room i 23 female my
husband 24 male just had our first baby
my husband was so excited and was super
supportive and caring throughout the
pregnancy
the only thing is that he became
slightly obsessed with watching youtube
and tick tock videos
of husbands pulling pranks on their
wives while in labor
i just got an idea for a different
series of youtube videos we have to do
now i didn't mind at first but then he
started casually joking about doing
things he saw in the videos saying it
would be funny i clearly stated my
distaste for them and asked him not to
do anything like what he saw he agreed
and continued to joke about it from time
to time but i brushed it off since i
trusted him and thought nothing would
come of it the day of the delivery came
and i had been in labor for eight hours
uh i had just finished another round of
contractions when my husband let out the
loudest fart turn to me and said what
the hell have you been eating it smells
disgusting i immediately recognized that
as one of the pranks in the videos
outraged at him not honoring what i
asked him not to do i demanded that he
leave the room
he started to argue saying that it was
just a joke but i insisted and luckily
the nurse helped him get out
the nurse helped him helped him leave i
went through the last four hours of
labor by myself since my family lives
out of state and i'm not close to my
mother-in-law
after the delivery i told the nurse he
could come back into the room and he was
fuming he started demanding that i tell
him why i kicked him out i calmly told
him the reason but he was pissed he
hasn't talked to me in a week his mom is
taking his side saying that i was a
complete for kicking him out normally he
will defend me from her but this time he
completely agreed
i might be the soul because i know how
much he was looking forward to being
there for the birth for our first kid
and especially when he got to cut the
cord but i still kicked him out and i
refused to let him back in the nurse
asked a few times if i wanted him back
in but each time i said no
so am i the over kicking my husband out
after a stupid prank that he agreed not
to do first of all your husband is the
a-hole purely because he spent weeks
researching delivery room pranks
and that's the one he settles on no
offense but you are a stupid [ __ ]
after weeks of watching all these videos
which do sound really hilarious and i
want to check some of that myself but
that's what you end up doing
just the best you could do after all
that time and all that prep you had
weeks man
and the best you could do was fart and
blame it on your wife
leaving that aside uh yeah he's the
a-hole because look
fellas
you antagonize your wife
while she's giving birth
and you get what you get daddy how you
feel
i feel sorry for you know you about as
much as i feel sorry for somebody who
gets eaten while wrestling a crocodile
it's like these are the choices you make
in life and you live with the
consequences
you knew what you were getting into
you knew the risks and you decided to do
it anyway
and besides third thing
um he's also kind of the a-hole for
being upset about being kicked out of
the delivery room i i've i've been
through this four times i would have
loved to get kicked out
who wants to be in the delivery room
anyway i know i'm one of the only guys
who will say this out loud but i tell
you right now i'm not the only guy who
feels this way that i don't re like it's
kind of gross and um i don't feel a
great need to be there i shouldn't have
gone in there i wish we could go back to
the days where men hung out this is what
they used to do back in the old days
okay
they had a smoking room in the hospital
and you would sit there while the woman
does all the delivery stuff and you
would just sit there you'd read a
newspaper and you'd smoke a cigar that's
right it's a baby and then when the
baby's born you'd go into the room you'd
say hello to the baby
and you'd leave and you'd check back in
about the time that they you know
graduate middle school that's the way it
should be okay
all right um next one am i thankful for
wanting my son to get along with my
boyfriend shawn is my 13 year old child
and i am a single mother connor my
current boyfriend of course his name is
connor and i have been together for two
years sean has disliked conor for as
long as you can remember he would go
upstairs and ignore conor whenever he
came to my place even though i let conor
drop sean off at school sean has never
once expressed appreciation or bonded
with conor connor pretended to be
unconcerned by his actions but i could
tell he was hurt by all of it i asked
him why he despised conor so much he
gave a list of various reasons some of
which i seriously doubt to begin with he
claims that when conor dropped him off
at school a couple of times he made
derogatory remarks about his asian
friends calling him a little kung pao
chicken
so it's not funny
sean mentioned the time connor didn't
give his guinea pig water
and when he and i were at the beach a
year ago he was house sitting for three
days sean also mentioned how connor
advised him to man up in a number of
circumstances i basically told him
straight up that i don't believe
anything he's saying i confronted conor
after that and he denied all of it so
because sean lied i took away his gaming
consoles as punishment i also lectured
him about abusing conor who might be his
new stepdad one day sean told his father
my ex what had happened
now my ex is cursing at me for being
unfair towards my son am i the okay
yeah you're the a-hole look i i don't
know your situation i don't know
why you aren't married to sean's dad but
what i do know is that what shawn wants
what all kids want is for their parents
to live together in the same house and
have a real intact family like they're
real parents both of them like that's
that's what shawn wants that's what your
kid wants and like if you can't handle
that grow the hell up and if they can't
have that for whatever reason you can't
blame them for being upset
or for not being especially fond of the
the runner-up prize
hey sean uh your dad and i you know you
can't have a real dad but here's connor
let's just settle on that instead and
besides
he's just your boyfriend
so sean doesn't know if this guy will be
actually a permanent fixture in your
life have you thought about that
how many let me ask you how many
boyfriends have you had
since
the father of your child
i'm guessing more than one
so how many times has shawn been
expected to develop a father-son
relationship with the new guy in your
life who just ends up getting you know
ends up out of the picture in a year or
two anyway you might have your hands
full once i'll pick up the control
though have you ever thought about the
fact that that there's this continual
uh effect of abandonment that your son
is going through and so now he's putting
up defense defenses against that because
he's tired of being abandoned
by one man after another
whether it's the man's fault or yours or
a combination probably a combination
have you thought about that well that's
it those judgments are absolutely final
and uh if you want to hear more of my
judgmental tone and everything else that
you get from this channel then make sure
that you uh you hit like and hit the
notification bell and you subscribe and
you better do it right now